how's it going bros my name is pete pat
and welcome to
oh that felt very 2012. what do you
think anger
wake up i need views look cute
[Music]
look cute look cute i care
it's a fake by the way okay
hey okay i got you it's not funny
okay wake up wake up there or else
it's not cute or funny to threaten your
dog with lethal weapons
come here i'm sorry
[Music]
sorry for almost killing you
why are you so sleepy all the time hello
hello are you depression hello wake up
be happy
anyway last week i asked you to pick my
new thumbnail photo
and lo and behold here it is the
greatest photo of me
ever taking thank you all right it will
be done
it will be done where the fricks the
axolotl this updates
the entire subreddit yeah i'm sorry for
missing
a split second of the bottom right of
the screen
that no one ever looks at thank you been
saving this shirt for my amputation i
watched food since the start of
secondary and already my 21st birthday
on
19th of june no legs
welcome to the no leg scan can i
i don't know how i feel about this joke
now biggest peepee right there hell yeah
oh everyone's so nice my man gets his
[ __ ] leg cut up and makes a meme
about it that's
massive balls and ginormous peepee right
there
happy birthday now no it didn't win
thank god this didn't win red egger that
would have been terrible
you say something
[Music]
when you realize that the minecraft
series started today two years ago
this is the new meme template for aging
what the frick is the axolotl yeah i
found it and it was the shitty brown one
i thought it was orange all right i'm
gonna kill him next episode
just wait huh floor gang two years ago
is this drawn from scratch it's so old
so fast
that's amazing flying straw i like it
i don't actually think flora gang was
two years ago
i just thought it would be funny to
exaggerate it oh
my god thick felix
think why would the letter y and the
letter j make the same sound
oh my god well they shouldn't make the
same sound
the j should be pronounced like the y
and the y should prevent something else
we can
fill it up with another sound
like like that sound
so if you say yeah you say uh it saves
you syllables
that's the whole point it's annoying
having to say
genes instead of just genes less effort
it flows from tongue better genes genes
it's the same syllables i understand the
difference but
the difference is it's less effort okay
i want less effort speaking
and don't even get me started how dumb
that oh but the
th this is what idiots say when they
defend this they're like oh but that's
just the rules
oh it's the rules okay you follow every
stinky dummy rule
okay so we got one sheet and the plural
is
mainly she makes sense totally makes
sense
good job english language oh we got we
got a goose
and the plural is what geese shut the
[ __ ] up
how about a moose what's the plural
moose moses
surely it's a means then plural of a
moose's mouse
it should be maze we're changing this
now all right just because someone said
well that's just how it is
oh it's not all it is i change it
hell yeah oh [ __ ] yeah
oh hell yeah oh okay
let's go it's fida dickie sorry
i mean it's called fang johnny d he
passed away no
he's no longer with us no i break my
heart
um he died of a heart attack oh
johnny surrounded by his wife and
friends and family
that's good at least johnny d for those
who don't know
legendary singer he had the voice of an
angel
all day i know you've been wait here we
go
congratulations woo it's a celebration
i just want to tell you that i think
you're amazing
you're amazing johnny d and my
condolences to the family
he did what he enjoyed to the very end i
respect that
a new pewdiepie minecraft video video
starting to become private
you were really even meme with 26
uploads because i forgot to put the ad
in for 10 minutes like damn
[Laughter]
it can't be that easy acts a lot of
chirps it's that easy yeah
come on guys come on time traveler cops
the timeline terraria oh my god
minecraft it actually looks it kind of
works in a weird way
what the [ __ ] okay i saw this amazing
some good news at least day by day
legendary
song maker sure let's call them that
look i don't know
congratulations happy for you bro let's
remove pewdiepie from his own channel
first thumbnail no oh thank god this
didn't win
sorry sorry better luck next time we
built gothenburg felix's hometown
one by one scale in minecraft that looks
sick
whoa oh no [ __ ] way
i gotta try this out is there a download
whoa
whoa
how impossible
[Music]
that's what is that is that that's my
house
what that's so trippy holy [ __ ] this is
blowing my mind
no [ __ ] way oh my god
whoa
[Music]
hey huge oh let's see nevada whoa
this one's for jargon oh [ __ ] yeah sub
well that that's insane thinking about
floor gang was two years ago
made you all feel all the night deny
it's only been one year
oh god it's been a year me thought about
my crush as a joke she falls in love
with me we finally get married i wake up
from my dream
ecky wake up wake up
it's not a dream it's reality oh it
actually worked hello
wait something explain what is it
it's gonna forgot you forgot you wanna
say
will i wake you up will i wake you up no
all right still asleep well
edgar what do we expect from edgar what
feeling
you can't even do that you slaves you're
useless
you're just sleeping you can't even see
it's actually really cute he put his
head on the desk
all right come on come on gotta gotta
get through the video
you very cute is this okay for the next
thumbnail
thank god this one didn't make it okay
this would have been good
after one year and six months i finally
beat pewdiepie and pewdiepie super
simulator
huge pp congratulations that's not easy
right anger are you impressed
edgar is impressed think felix think oh
he posted it on twitter
all right and he's getting mean all
right go go to sleep then
why would you poop in this [ __ ] because
i had no choice
it's such a good meme template oh okay
so i didn't get the rare blue variant
i got the cyan i am once again
asking for cooking with pewdiepie maybe
i want to make some pie yeah i love
pewdiepie okay the name hundred of his
videos
love that's on me i set the bar too
[Music]
[Laughter]
true can't lie can't find it you're so
dumb you mining diamonds with the stone
pickaxe
this is fake fake news broadly
delete it here's the move during videos
we can't pierce moses during live
streams
well i found them okay stop complaining
nobody
snakes once a month oh ee ah i need to
get out of my skin
it's true it's funny because true can't
find lie
oh that's so cute angevar and his
girlfriend
toasty egg bar as well oh
apparently they need shelter they like
the dark
i didn't realize this i need to build
him something cute it's axolotl he's so
ugly
i love him
yeah okay so i complain about the orbs
looking uh
or is looking different and then people
point out well that's because they made
it more accessible for people with color
blindness
so great i feel like an [ __ ] thank
you
but there's still a color makes no sense
all right colorblind people just
uh look i'm getting cancelled okay
moving on
where's edgar he's probably doing dumb
stuff do
by
african famine of 22 like africa
hell yeah it tastes so good people
starve
yummy yummy yummy who looks like this
though okay so i was reviewing
this dub campaign and they made bottles
shaped like different body types
but again big end looks like that i
don't know how i didn't see that
edgar if you're being held as hostage by
pewds
bark twice in next video i know you use
reddit
edgar okay
tell them tell them how they're how
you're kept safe
huh okay
tell them tell them how much you enjoy
it here
he looks like such a little pig
[Music]
they look like a beta a beta you're a
beta
you're pathetic you're not my child
there
it is oh i'm the long one you did it
right
huge people a thumbs up you got it right
dj guy at pewd's wedding what's my
purpose you
we gave you playlists just to play the
playlist all you need to produce press
play you are nothing
okay maybe i was a little harsh on the
dj he didn't do a good job at the end of
the evening i'm not gonna lie we had a
great time
i'm sorry who edits pewdiepie pewdiepie
edits all of his own videos so i wear
this videos for 23 hours a day
[Music]
thank you side thanks side i almost
missed this amazing fan art
that's so cool my mom congratulations
congratulating me for waking up at 2pm
you are the best dog i'm sorry you win
all of the awards
all right some great submissions this
week thank you guys as always
don't worry edgar is safe he's happy
he live happy life right there girl you
love it
you want breakfast you want bro for the
camera you want to find
it all right here we go
[Music]